oh
he did not expect that that was awesome citizens
of the reject Nation how are you on this fine day
it is time to dive back in to the DC Animated
Universe with Son of Batman how you doing John
I am great to do you know what just let me
say I I've been looking forward to the next
time you've been away and we haven't shot one of
these in a minute yeah and when Greg came up with
this idea to put us together I was already super
excited and now this is like one of my favorite
only all-time things to do on the channel it's
the best like thank you so also thank you okay
sex reject nation and for you guys for for being
so responsive this is such a blast yeah if you
guys didn't comment like And subscribe which I
would encourage you to do to comment like And
subscribe we couldn't do it because it wouldn't
grow because YouTube algorithms so do comment
like subscribe so we can keep doing these because
this shirt says sons of the Batman if we watch
enough of these maybe this movie will be called
that retroactively by having more Sons because
there's many Robins I assume that's the plot
we haven't seen this you haven't seen this I
haven't seen this at all and remember if you want
to watch this all the way through the syncing up
one to one start to finish all the way through do
become a patron that way you can join us for the
entire Journey all the little beats all the little
moments want to know what our resting faces look
like be a patron want to know what things got cut
be a patriot want to know if we swear more we do
be a patron I actually don't know what the plot of
this one is because I knew a bit about Flashpoint
having read the comic I knew kind of what war
had to be I have no idea what the implication
is here so we're about to find out together our
very first watch of Son of Batman let's do it
[Music]
PG-13 intrigues me oh I missed
that logo that's beautiful
I missed that logo yeah oh little Batman's
in it though a little surprise that is cool
I'm a sucker for the 90s Circle DC myself
I feel you Kyle Rainer era Superboy era
[Music]
the business to defeat the Huns I'm
Gonna Make a Man Out of all these guys
here is your inheritance the League of
Assassins they will be yours to command
to make certain the Earth abides a natural
contentment that's John Carlo I think it is
it is good to see our revered father so
devoted to his grandson yes brother it is
take the boys dang
[Music]
my bad that's why is Al ghoul we're gonna find out
how they pronounced it place your
bets Choose Your Own Adventure
foreign
I like the use of mirroring animation for how
well-trained the soldiers are
because it works twice yeah
they all brought a bunch of knives to a gunfight
come on now and a helicopter helicopter fight
sweet
good shot
that's Selena right [Laughter] should calum's
just hanging out with uh not her dad Italia
[Music] oh
damn kid trained you well
oh nice rock beats helicopter
a league of silhouettes
[Music]
was that a Wilhelm scream it was very close sound
kind of like a Wilhelm scream he's mine confused
old man slain oh [Music] how could you have
pushed me out I was your right hand oh interesting
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
500 years the world's had
quite enough of you old man
the Lazarus Pit will not bring you back this time
we'll see about that [Music]
oh let's see what the Son of Batman can do oh
dang it's still 80 pounds
[Music]
cool I'll make you suffer for this boy next time
you guys are gonna have to modernize your game
I mean they got an arrow Gatling gun frankly
what else do you do that's clearly they won
too cooler
oh the bottle of Xanax
we have to get him into the Lazarus Pit
somebody help him out 27. damn stop we
have to try we can't just leave him he's
dead this is what the Lazarus Pit is for some
continuities it can't depends on who's writing we
we have to move come where are we going
Gotham City time to meet your father [Music]
alimony payments are over you
Waylon Jones AKA Killer Croc stealing drugs isn't
your usual Mo but Exposition is when half the
biotech firms in town get hit I get curious
you look like you've been working out Croc
is he ever not it's a pretty big guy
oh bummer
[Music]
yes the bat forklift never leave home
without it that's Jason O'Mara Batman
back is it I was trying to place
it I think you're right I think so
stop fighting in the Indiana Jones Warehouse
with your bare fists against the Killer Croc
the problem with steroids is
I'll get the munchies [Laughter]
[Music] you should have warned your
playdate I'm the only one who can bite you
shocked to see me it's not the Arnold
Mr Freeze movie that'd be a different
electrifying entrance though yeah their
chemistry really is electric you remember
our shared moonlight some of it the best
parts conceiving our son he doesn't know
he's gonna find out the weirdest way assassins
plan to take over racist organization they are
led by a man who father believed could be his
successor now this man wants to kill us us me
and your son son what did you say
that day you expect me to believe
this I assure you he's yours we asked Maury
it looks just like both of us look at him
well I guess I'll watch the kid she thinks
she'll be better off with me what do you
think better than with the League of
Assassins they taught me how to fight
I take it not much else I'll teach you
how to drive yeah you become a man today
I like that Batmobile yeah it's pretty sweet
good thing I brought the two-seater sweet
great looking Gotham too yeah I like the
art deco as much as they can bring it back
Mom said leave your test tubes and come now
she has dinner I'm close to a breakthrough
you're always close to a breakthrough I'm doing
it for us oh making something turn blue in a tube
my meth is the best meth perhaps I could use
a bite I'm starting to see double here wait up
injured well the rest of the servants I am the sum
total you have only one servant he's not a servant
he's a friend hear that
Alfred yeah heartwarming kind
he is the spitting image of you at that age you're
gonna have to get him settled I'm not sure how
long he'll be here but for the time being this
will be his home he just left like I just took
off on a boat prepare some tea pennyworth brown
sugar instead of whites fresh cut lemon a China
cup perhaps Master would like some warm mixed
nuts and a moist hand towel I'm not so young
that I don't understand sarcasm well I am much
too old to care yeah I just want them to fight
yeah the whole set of Batman
to Damian I miss him already
I'm proceeding according to plan ah you
seem to think I'm part of the old agreement
I am not from this point on I will be arranging
separate accommodations for your family ew
in Hell Rachel ghoul has been retired I am his
successor you will call me Deathstroke Deathstroke
this is a pretty cool mask pull I
like the little chin strap harness
to keep it tucked he's been at it
since five o'clock this morning
I hope you don't mind sir the sword is your
grandfather's the one on the wall plaque
too you should get a job as a
gardener only so many bushes yeah
what's the rest of the yard look like
yeah when he's gonna start beheading
these topiaries wait for his dad to show up
not the giraffe it took months to grow then
what the hell the profit margin is down
in Argentina someone is skimming Revenue
that's my division Bruce it's okay it's all
right I'll deal with this what are you doing
reviewing my Birthright Deathstroke killed my
grandfather he has to pay race was a Madman
he was a hero he died a hero 's Deathstroke's
right-hand man he used to work my grandfather
he stays in Gotham City between missions
to indulge his vices you downloaded this
from the computer in the Batcave didn't you I
hacked into NORAD when I was six it was easy
wait I like that he got his little turtleneck
and slacks where to get those little clothes
man he made them no stops you will not go
off on your own for any reason you will
stay away from the Batcave computer and you
will stay out of sight do you understand I
own my grandfather a [Music] not a yes
young man nope not even close [Music]
Hogwarts looks nice this time of year
it's the crossover we need zatana and Harry
Potter let's do it justice league dark foreign
Deathstroke is mine yes he will be proclaimed this
will go well why are they all running like that
anime kid it's the most efficient way to run it
saves money on animation [Laughter] how you run
[Music]
oh cool way of showing speed
that was rad I like that
we mean let's do it let's do it
Arkham Asylum could be anybody
they're like if we Cameo I mean frankly what
even doing we at least have to show everyone's
face or silhouette you got the last fix you're
gonna get from langstrom where is he screw you
[Applause] they don't want to
get too close but I'm not afraid
you help me I'll help you I'll
take you to Lazarus Pit right now
clean off growing back you know I assume I hope
nice [Music]
cool nice oh no we got a Man-Bat
please tell me we have a man band
this might just be bat bats but
I got oh maybe hope for bandbat
oh I think we got it oh what
gonna go we get Gorilla yeah whoa
I thought maybe Grodd but nope winged gorilla
right in the ape nips [Music] [Applause] oh damn
foreign yeah I was gonna say he's
fine giant Wizard of Oz monkey just
came out of nowhere I did not expect
that but a curveball yeah the wicked
witch is behind all this oh that's the
secret check out rash she wanted that
youthful serum for herself yeah I'm
just gonna bathe in the Lazarus but
[Music]
it's using your noodle bats still understand
how water towers work me neither because it's
not like the water like comes directly out of them
into the city like I just don't I don't know what
they do it's just for safe keeping it's for fun
a big aquarium I hope there's no cameras in here
and you're gonna have to keep this window shut
if you want me to take my things off whoa dang
this ain't your grandpappy's Batman
I'm going to give you to the count of three one
three
nice
leave harlots
just trying to make a living man sex
work has worked Damien called him harlots
dang serious
[Music]
where is Deathstroke did you that easy just ask
and I would talk I don't want it to be easy sure
oh yeah let's go buddy
you're running from a child I know
I mean he just whooped you but still
can't feel good about yourself in
this moment no he's embarrassed
so damn we do not vehicular manslaughter people
no Gotham safe drivers we do Frogger though yes
crunchy [Music]
you'll get nothing from me either I get
answers or you get the sword [Music]
oh no yeah had to be
he did not expect that that was
awesome I heard you called my suit
girly little brother talk missing
something whoa says he's your son
Damien messed him up dude oh that was clever
that was really clever World building quickly
established both of them yeah are you
all right Master dick I took the cut
I can take the Stitch maybe you need more
anesthetic and maybe you need to go faster
yes ah the Neil gaming oh not Neil Gaiman
Neil um Adam suit that's cool this was yours
still is is this what you were
in training it's what I wore
when I went on patrol the only thing
it's missing is lace trim and a son
would be a good look I know what you're thinking
you're thinking you could be Robin well you can't
I don't need some insipid costume and a bird name
I'm Way Beyond your kind of simplistic training as
you saw tonight don't forget you lost that fight
yeah you did how's ubu it's got more monitors
connected to him than Arkham has fluid he takes
I'll stay in touch he doesn't deserve to breathe
if it hadn't been for him if it hadn't
been for dick you'd have gone too far
it's easier my way it has nothing to
do with easy it's about doing what's
right because it's right and that's the only
reason you need yeah heads up good reflexes
what if I had missed [Music] it would
have hurt I want to help like he used to
it's bad enough you've given yourself away
and let them know we're on to them but you're
letting Vengeance guide your actions you've never
felt vengeful every day let me tell you a kid
stay close that's an order I can do that
wait a minute I'm not gonna like this
nope nope yes
dang okay okay you let him have pants
that's good yes Robin pants how's ubu
doing we searched his place nothing much
there but we did find one interesting item
it's a phone say a phone chat line
it's what's written on the
other side for a good time
what could have been dad used to bring me here
for ball games sometimes afterward we go to the
amusement park and now history repeats itself
let's go I don't need your amusing [__] Batman
building respect
Dr langstrom
Deathstroke has my family where is Deathstroke
I don't know I'll make you talk Robin no
he's just a scientist
no swords fine
you see you don't need it
hmm
oh yeah do the Black Widow yeah
I'm no coward don't be stupid
listen oh no the creatures
man bats all right we got
him I'll take it I'll take it
waiting for this day we got our man
bats plural I didn't expect plural yeah
it's a man Battalion they're
having a man battle they are
more Man-Bat puns as for the patrons
okay now what [Music]
oh yeah yep yep yep always trust the
tech he's always ready with the tech
where's Victor Stone gonna play football now
where's Bane gonna have a
speeches oh Robin [Music]
wanted me to splice animal DNA to human
using Advanced mutagens he wanted you to
make the ultimate warriors yes damn
where's your family I don't know my
daughter mentioned something about snow
about two two mountain peaks that she said
look like cat ears yep grandfather's
compound you're I'm sure [Music]
going to Hogwarts let's go into
Hogwarts the owls have arrived
Damien's a Slytherin yeah
it is definitely a Slither
your romance with the Dark Knight wasn't merely
rumor who is he do it you must I won't talk
I believe you I was being crumbly Humanity like my
grandfather by killing if that's what it took how
do you hope to lead Humanity when you've never
been a part of it your childhood wasn't a lot
of fun either I also had people around me to help
I had friends all you've had are trainers there's
a difference Damien yeah you need people skills
[Music] oh nothing [Music] good parenting listen
a false wall oh nice I want one yep
[Music] please don't hurt us
we're not here to hurt you
Batman we've been so afraid you're all right now
Robin you saved us oh this is totally unnecessary
to stroke said he would spare us if I gave
this to you what don't tell Batman oh no oh no
this is between you and me leave the sperm donor
out of it wow wow cheese dude I'll give you 48
hours before I end her suffering be worthy
of your heritage boy make your mother proud
John Wu directed that shot imagine a John Woo
superhero film would be crazy he already doesn't
believe in physics it'd just be pure Madness
sword fighting motorcycles again a dormant
oil rig belonging to Race part of a shell company
went active a few weeks back that is interesting
hold on Damien yep where's the oil rig Scotland
off the outer Hebrides what's wrong he's gone
and took his uniform Bruce chill the rig is 50
miles off the coast what's he gonna do swim there
big shell and of course he swim he's
training yeah everything is training
[Music]
well done little Solid Snake
cardboard box it up yeah [Music]
stay on alert if so much as a seagull
tries to land on this rig shoot it mine
no
he knows you're following him he must he has to
be Deathstroke is that a tribute to king shark
just then it has to be but you can't get him
it's a kid that's weird we didn't have any kids
[Music]
foreign
bats just waiting I wouldn't
make any threatening moves
they'll stay put as long as I tell them to the
only thing this rig pumps is life Everlasting
to the highest bidder looks like your mother
could use it now this is what they call a standoff
not even the pit can bring back Mommy
if her head's blown off your play Damien
I should congratulate you for getting this
far but that would be like applauding a suit
ouch so entitled so bloodthirsty
so easy to manipulate
I brought you here for one simple reason to
kill you goodbye boy run Damien oh selfless Act
foreign boss you're certainly not dead shot at
this Deathstroke nope uh see what you did there
kill them I'm bad at shooting
yeah I had one job to do
more of a sword man yes yes smart
oh that's that's wow
[Music]
no I'll end him I swear [Music] yeah that's what
I'm afraid she's not suggesting to you foreign
nope
oh good
oh this is not gonna be pumping life much
longer you're not you don't put stuff underwater
yeah not especially if you're going
to have like a destructive bat Army
with little to no discretion mindless in
tubes oh Nightwing save the day yeah yeah
[Music]
damn you're a quick study doc [Music]
who's that uh we're gonna drown they
are not saving them yep all right
I hope they can all swim [Music]
[Laughter] nothing I'm not laughing at anything
it's tally always in like a cat suit like this oh
they literally leaned a little aggressively
on the every outfit as boobs in it I'm not
used to that it's just end like the one time
she was in civilian clothes was the same yeah
Talia would have been mine as well until your
father came along and created something special
ah Jesus
[Music]
out by the hilts just just went for it I
mean to survive I guess I feel that [Music]
still swinging those swords though he's got
adrenaline he's just very thick forearms
oh [__] stroke
I know what that smells like like absinthe
it looks like ooh the Phoenix Force [Music]
cool nice
[Music]
now [Music]
your luck ends you call it luck I call it skill
about it my one good eyes I knew
you would save us I haven't yet
oh Batman chose love the whole place is collapsing
no the Lazarus juice last one
saved from that absence of joy
oh nice cool
[Music]
his arms are just so toasty
he's gonna be in double casts
get that last Lazarus juice just
dunk your arms in it boy [Music]
maybe it'll heal his eye you were trained to
kill your enemies weren't you it's what you want
I would do grandfather would do but not what
your dad would do I'm my Father's son too
not bad get in
dang I guess this would have
like an escape rocket have to
the owl I'm not gonna save you
either that's not murder no
come on Kiera Nightwing
foreign
good old bat magnet suction cups never leave
the cave without them I thank you for my life
and the life of my son our son I need to
rebuild the league make it stronger better
Harder Faster I'm gonna kill more
efficiently Damien should stay with me
he will want to be with his mother he's Robin now
he stays with the Batman uh are you ready to come
if that's your wish mother learn from your Father
Damien for he is very wise and you are the future
you got this Damien I will come
back for him make him great I will
shared custody if only people could
solve problems with more swords [Music]
God what a beautiful sky just a couple of
Batman let's go home Damien I'll drive no I know
oh good button right there I like that
yeah no it's a nice way to leave that off
um all right D Bradley Baker was all the Mad bats
Giancarlo hell yeah David McCallum was Alfred cool
casket right all right we're in a back room with
that Comet cred I know Deadpool and this she must
be a comic book fan I like that the robin Cape had
that little bit of like kind of like fur like the
black over the yellow or like yeah or feathers
yeah whatever that was I like that look because
you can't quite discern that in the comics all
the time like he definitely has some like Fringe
accent yeah I liked that I like how it moved yeah
it was a cool design and they gave him pants and
pants they gave him Robin pants I think we're
gonna get a decent amount of robins in the uh
the James Gunn take on Batman because it's one of
the few things they haven't really done yet yeah
and I've heard in recent times some interesting
please for why we should have other people want
the Robin and and kind of how interesting
and and somewhat peculiar it is that so
many filmmakers have been so opposed it's really
hard to do right like it's it's very easy to get
Robin wrong uh you know it's it's a ward uh it's
like you know something that lives in your house
it's just the the suit can be in this handled
the character give me this handled and also
it's really like a a a deeper end of the story
Batman Choice than they've really done in a while
that's fair you need to really build them
up I think they're just going to throw us
into it this time though I think we're gonna get
about Batman that's already pretty established I
think he's gonna have a bat family uh I also
think that it will be a way to distinguish
from the Batman Universe I think that's a good
idea yeah and like I honestly think that you
know I talked about the duality of Batman I think
Flashpoint when I was saying how like the villain
can be opposite of Batman in so many
different ways was that flash point
but like I think Robin represents another
antithesis a Batman of like was it during
Red Hood it was red hood that's it yeah it seems
like it would make sense to be talking about that
shirt Batman was in Red Hood wasn't he uh but I
think Robin represents another antithesis but in
a way that's heroic as opposed to like the villain
being the antithesis like what if what if Batman
was raised you know in a different environment is
Damian Wayne so I think it'd be really interesting
to have that character in a movie like not the
first one I think well maybe the first one it
depends how deep they want to go but I think I
think a son of Batman like this would be really
interesting like live action Choice yeah with
Aiden Gallagher that's wetcast Aiden Gallagher
where would I have seen this lab he was uh the
young gentleman from Umbrella Academy uh okay
okay precocious little uh ax older than his age
he's the young one yeah the young one the one
that's like 30 going on seven or whatever like
that kid yeah I think he'd be pretty exceptional
just just from the little brief glimpses I've had
I'm like yeah that makes sense yeah yeah I can see
that just gotta make him get buffed buff child
keep him in the comics great night Nightwing man
great Nightwing introduction great Nightwing use
yeah I love that I love the way they Incorporated
Nightwing here no post-credits scene nothing we
found out in real time because they're like we
should put Atlantis next we should probably use it
we should get back on we've LED people to expect
people wanted more Batman we threw it in let's
get back to the throne of Atlantis absolutely
uh so what do you think I enjoyed this man it was
fun this was really fun this was a character like
Damian Wayne is a character I'm aware of and have
seen in you know limited takes on I haven't really
got a ton of like I know more Robins than I do
know uh Damien Wayans but I thought this was a
cool story and I liked the way that they built
the character because at first Damien is a bit
frustrating he's he's a very frustrated character
but not in the way you know like that it's easy
to make that off-putting or it's easy to make it
uh such that you can't come back and and regain
the you know affection for the character once
the growth happens and here I appreciated that
yeah there's still tons more growth to to to
occur for Damien and between him and Bruce but
I like the little ways in which you can tell like
okay Damien is sort of coming around to uh Bruce's
way of doing things and is at least you know like
inclined to listen a little bit because he is out
of his element even though he has you know a an
Elite Training background and all that other stuff
it's not the only thing that matters yeah so yeah
I really like the way that they uh drove their
relationship and used other characters like Alfred
and Nightwing to bring some humor out and to show
that like yeah everybody is kind of dabbing a deal
with this kid right now and we are kind of along
for the ride with them you can see that we want
to see things work out with Batman and all that
but uh but yeah what do you think so I like the
paternal element you get from like the reason I
like Damian Wayne in the comics is it allows Bruce
to be a different person and like we didn't get a
lot of that but the moments we had were great like
the the fair moment like the flashback versus like
I like that the Damian Wayne had Bruce Wayne's
hairline so like when you saw him as a flashback
you see that like he looks just like you master
Wayne like I really like the paternal element
um because you know Robin's all were always kind
of like surrogate sons of Batman and I was worried
about the character uh when I heard about him I
was like really just gonna make it because it I
thought it would undermine I I think um adoption
is super important and I think that uh the way we
perceive family is super important I think that
like families not just blood like I think what
you choose to do around people you love makes
them family so I was worried that him having a
blood son would undermine the other Robins sure
like then they'd like lean too far and be like
well he's got Sons like why are we making a son
why is it that what a redundancy yeah and then
like the way it then makes it about Talia and
the league is more interesting because of that
connection so I don't feel like it undermines
you know Tim or or dick or Stephanie Brown or
any of the other Robin's uh you know uh that we
currently have but it does add another element to
his sons because there's like one son that's got
a different connection that's fun yeah so I I like
it actually I think it's enhanced the bat family
and it was nice to see because because you know
having under the Red Hood uh uh in mind uh you
know I feel like Damien the story could easily
kind of Teeter on that territory because so much
of the argument there is about you know not going
too far not having the Killer Instinct there's
all that competition between them um but here
I thought that they did nicely to not make it too
much like that despite the similarities and two I
like that yeah you have Batman in a position to
while he's doing his Batman thing having to be
more concerned like a father would be and then
having uh these at least hints at you know the
The Backs round with him and Talia and stuff like
that at least having her like as as much as I was
a little taken aback by her like again just like
cat suit you know like presents hey Batman yeah
I'm not quite used to catch it sometimes but it's
not like all tits like that's they really well
that's really like she's not very well protected
frankly as far as violence goes she's exposed yeah
yeah I feel like in certain ways and again that's
also a character who I haven't seen a million
takes on their other Batman characters I'm more
familiar with but in that in that opening battle
she did kind of feel like a Catwoman character
her nimbleness the agility like a lot of those
things yeah and the and the sultriness that she
proceeds with you know alongside her great sense
of purpose you know all that I do like uh that
speaking of like Talia and multiple characters
that this was able to balance you know Killer Croc
uh Man-Bat uh Natalia and Ross race relationships
man bad showed up like there's a lot it's juggling
Deathstroke didn't feel shortchanged for having
other you know villains in it like Deathstroke
still got his time really read this how it in
the comics is Deathstroke a character that gets
used and called upon a lot because from watching
the movies and in these animated movies especially
it seems like Deathstroke it gets a lot at screen
time he's pretty prevalent like he's kind of the
go-to Assassin like he's he's very much like the
guy but on the Marvel side I see Taskmaster
as his equivalent and Taskmaster is not used
quite as much like like he's used a lot and I
think that's why people were bummed with black
widow's choice to make it not a power but make
it something like technological so I like that
Deathstroke uh is a character that seems to get
like he doesn't get killed like and I feel like
that's important like he he can't always come
back so I assume he doesn't we didn't see a body
um but also he's not daddy's Taskmaster yeah but
I mean you see this problem uh he's Deathstroke
but I do think Deathstroke is going to be a
foundational part of the new DC Universe as well
because I feel like all those characters we almost
got like are the ones that were just set up like
mangiliano like playing them like we're gonna see
them get to flourish because Deathstroke is pretty
prevalent yeah okay cool but yeah I dug this I
think uh they juggled a lot uh I think they told
the story well uh I I for some reason like at the
beginning I said like I don't know what story this
is going to be like as soon as I was confirmed it
was Damian Wayne which I should have assumed uh
like I I didn't know if it was going to be more
of the vague Robin element I also don't remember
how recently Damien was introduced before this
animated I think he's like 2000 10 but I don't
know for sure that was gonna be my next question
is how recent of a character because the robins
seemed to I mean you know Robin Dick goes back
like way far and then you know you have the other
Robins who I associate as being at least around
for a good while now and Damien strikes me as the
most recent he's definitely the most recent of the
core Robins like there's alternate universes and
all that stuff but like I mean Jim starlin's the
one that wrote Robin getting killed and I think
that was in the late 70s early 80s so like you
know with the vote with the vote the vote that's
now 40 years ago okay which is crazy to think
about yeah man that's bananas and it's only going
to get crazier the further along we trudge down
the timeline yeah I mean this this movie's almost
10 years old 2014 was like 10 years ago I haunts
me that is a terrifying statistic don't love the
2014 feels like the future like it doesn't even
feel past like when I say 2014 like that's coming
up yeah any time now anything past 2010 does still
feel like it's somehow kind of the future teen
after 20 it's like that's yeah crazy 2004 sounds
dated but 2014 does not it's almost a decade since
2014. yeah we are approaching Blade Runner 2049
rapidly but yeah I dug this uh I'm excited for
more um of this universe I did feel like this
was more it's interesting because Flashpoint
apparently starts this and then Justice League
Ward didn't feel connected to Flashpoint now and
I understand it starts a Multiverse but this then
felt like the standard Universe of Batman from
the comic book and Justice League War felt like an
alternate universe so I feel like we've got three
different universes so far yes I'm like do you
feel the same I do I'm very fascinated to see how
these line up and how they build upon each other
because this it's funny this feels more totally
akin to what we saw with like under the Red Hood
right which is not attached to any of this yeah
yeah and so this did a nice job of at least like
you have the Jason O'Meara Batman back so you have
that piece of connective tissue and this story is
much more contained and personal so it breathes
in a different way that I uh appreciated but yeah
looking at the progression thus far it has felt
I guess somewhat disjointed this doesn't feel
quite as disjointed as Justice League War only
because it is actually at least taking the one
character from that and or Flashpoint I should say
um but and it feels like the culture this one
was the Jason O'Mara I feel like that may have
been flash boy damn we gotta do our that's the
thing let me go back because it's hard to tell
why they're in this order because yeah so far and
that's what's exciting is apparently there's 49
of these but like how do they connect and what
is that relation we're gonna find out in real
time because this doesn't feel like a sequel
to war or that it sets up Throne of Atlantis
and I get that there's like a Justice League
through line and then there's side missions
but I'm just confu I'm excited yeah excited to
see how it connects yeah this was fun glad we're
doing these uh if you want us to do more of these
like comment you're probably already subscribed
if you're not get on it hit that notification
Bell we can only keep doing these people keep
watching them because otherwise it's weird to tape
it otherwise we're just gonna watch them without
you guys we'll just watch this cuddle on the couch
and snuggle up and watch private and cast many
singers as the players in the in the DC Universe
and that you won't get on on these watch along
so please do comment share show your friends uh
and if you want to watch it sync to sync one to
end Slide the line join a patreon and see it
all the way through with this all synced up
um this uh this has been fun we're gonna we're
gonna do Justice League Throne of Atlantis next
which is the post-credits scene of the last
movie it's gonna be good next to find out
what Aquaman was up to what was he doing just
swimming talking to fish where was he direct
this this is all happened it was a lot of water
he was talking another shark he sent that shark
do you set the Sharks he's like yo get that man
I got you yeah yeah yeah Jason Momoa going yeah
my man it bites him yeah yeah it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good all right appreciate you thank
you for being here thank you for watching
uh let us know what your favorite of these
animated movies are let us know what you thought
of this one let us know if we're wrong about what
predictions are to come but don't spoil anything
because I'm very curious how 49 movies connect
that are so far doing this at us all right
we'll see you soon reject Nation much love
foreign